[Music]
hey guys good morning thank you for
being here despite all the partying last
night I'm glad to see people bright and
early for the cloud native resource
management breakout before we get
started let's do a brief round of
introductions Greg the staff software
engineer etsy where I work on search bin
at Etsy for nine years Michael Ames
Michael Kibby I'm a software engineer on
the cloud native resource management
team here at Google and my name is sanam
Saxena I'm a product manager at Google
I support the cloud deployment manager
team which is the team behind the
product that we are going to be
unveiling today I've been in various
p.m. rows for about 16 years now and I'm
relatively new to Google so about nine
months in before we get started let's
get a bit of housekeeping out of the way
I would highly recommend opening up the
cloud next app on your phone the app
allows you to ask and abort questions
it's super easy to use
just look for cloud native resource
management session click on the Dory Q&A
button and start asking or reporting
questions that other in the audience are
asking and to get you warmed up
I've actually thrown up a question on
Dory for for Gregg because I love to
help him and so without further delay
let's get started and talk about what we
are covering today we are announcing a
new product config actor and we are
really excited to tell you all about it
a conflict actor is going to allow you
to use cue cuddle to manage your GCP
resources we are going to give your
familiar old cube cuddle new superpowers
how we are going to tell you and show
you later in the talk our goal is to
have for you to have one C ICD pipeline
that you deal with on a day-to-day basis
the one that drives all your cue petal
invocations but as I tell my kids you
have to eat your vegetables before you
can eat desert and to get everyone in
the audience on the same page I'm going
to start with a bit of a
free lesson I'm specifically going to be
talking about two separate trends adapt
adoption of in fracture s code and the
rise of Cuban IDs and then I'm going to
talk about the problems that we see
because of that stacking and then dive
into the solution that we are building
we will then shift gears and get into
the exciting part of the presentation
Gregg has an explosive demo lined up for
us and he's going to talk through how
HCS has adopted GCP and his experience
around using the product obviously and
then we'll end with KB Greg and I taking
questions from the dory and from the
audience if that sounds good let's start
with something a customer told me last
year so as you are reading this remember
this is a company that vast majority of
people in this room probably use or at
least have heard of I redacted their
name as getting legal approval in time
for next comes with it own sets of
pedals so to put this in context this
company's forward leaning they have
infrastructure on-prem on gke on GCP but
given that g key is declarative and GCP
is imperative they run into the problem
of fragmented management language matrix
so how did we end up over here to
understand that let's talk about the
first secular trend that has taken the
world by storm the adoption of interest
is code it seems like a lifetime away
but only a few years back many of us in
this room was still doing configuration
by hand
however as public cloud providers of
achieve multiple nine reliability own
iron fracture increasingly errors are
not caused because of hardware problems
but because somebody fat-fingered an
extra zero pressed the wrong button for
the most part we can you know all agree
that a manual configuration is mostly
behind us and the advantage of putting
everything in gate is tremendous once
you have everything in gate and you can
start applying basically the last 30
years of software management best
practices to these resources and you can
start treating and structure as zeros
and ones and leveraging good workforce
to do some very interesting things and
let me give you three examples of what I
have seen customers do the first example
is approval flows in highly regulated
environments so if you're walking
working a startup you may laugh at this
that some companies have to get approval
from their VP or directors of IT before
you can approve spend on fracture at a
certain level however if you're in
finance insurance government healthcare
being able to leverage get workforce for
approvals is is not only a nice-to-have
feature but it's a regulatory
requirement another great example is the
notion of pre submit check
GCB recently released a product called
config validator it's an EAP that allows
you to ensure that your policies and
structure articulated in code are not in
violation but their overall organization
policies so imagine a scenario where you
spin up a cloud function for a few
seconds configure editor ensure that the
function is compliant saving you hours
of rework or even worse later and my
last example is my favorite code Reds
not that I like code Reds but it's a
good example I met a little customer
last year in New York who has a pre
agreed template on who gets access to
water resources in case of a Code Red
scenario if something bad really happens
and she is able to give hundreds of
Engineers access to GCP environments in
case something bad happens additionally
because this is now part of a code
branch that her leadership has agreed
upon she's able to simulate a Code Red
drill giving developers the access they
need to fix the issues that they are
seen and to roll back the access once
the fix has been found and deployed and
the best part of the story is that you
don't have to be at sea or snap to take
advantage of these DevOps practices
fortune 500 companies government
agencies are adopting these workflows so
that they can recover from failure
faster deploy more often and deploy more
quickly and all of this has been very
exciting as in the last few years many
startups have established and
established players have entered into
the fray and trying to simplify how you
manage and deploy in fracture as I see
this this kind of happened in in three
waves I started with CI cd4 code which
is now pretty well established and your
lot of options to choose from
then configured Scott came in it's part
of the second wave with Google's cloud
deployment manager chef balloony
terraform leading the way and everything
for code is starting to take off with
customers wanted to put their
policies the router configurations
firewall rules VP sees everything into
gate and all with all these different
tools and services in the space
customers have a broad set of options
and standards and languages to choose
from and often these options and
standards do not work well with each
other but we will talk about that in a
bit later for now let's shift gear and
talk about the next secular trend that I
have been observing the rise in adoption
of communities for many of you in this
room this is not news however given the
diversity of the audience and let me
quickly talk to some publicly available
data and what is driving the adoption of
communities over the first few years we
have seen Q it is steadily gaining in
usage on every platform but nowhere has
it been more popular than on GCP as most
of you are aware given it is was
originally developed at Google and we
continue to lead the innovation in this
space according to a survey by rated out
organizations running containers in GCP
more than 85% orchestrate workloads with
communities in Azure which has offered a
managed community server service for
about two years now
roughly 65% of organizations are using
containers are also using humanities
humanities is literally everywhere our
customer run their own team I discussed
us and diverse environments and all
three major cloud providers now for a
managed bloom IT service as well so what
is driving this adoption and for you
know just for like just to get into that
like hey what is driving this think back
like you know back in the day to you
know when you to update software or when
you're pushing on you develop deployment
there's usually a lot of downtime and I
remember doing my organizational white
upgrades at midnight or over the weekend
when user traffic while at a minimum
continuously deploying new features with
downtime does not increase velocity the
goal is to update the application
without any downtime as your users
expect a constant uptime therefore
velocity is measured through the number
of features you could ship per hour
while still maintaining a highly
available service the cool concepts of
communities which enable high velocity
are immutability decorative
configuration and self-healing system so
as far as your developers are concerned
they apply the in fracture in
communities using cue petal apply and
they can focus on higher level functions
and not
downtown also has your product gross you
have to scale both your software and
views working on it so Q bilities
achieve scalability by favoring
decoupled micro service architectures in
a decoupled architecture each component
is separated from other components by
defined api's and service load balances
ApS provide a buffer between implementer
and consumer and load balancers provide
a buffer between running instances of
each service decoupling components while
your balances makes it easier to scale
the program that make up your service
because increasing the size of the
program can be done without adjusting or
reckoning any of the other layers of
your service let's talk about separation
of concern this topic should resonate
really well video when Google builds a
service as a consumer of their service
you don't really care about how we go
about building their service similarly
in queue Manatee is the application
developer relies on the SLA delivered by
the container orchestration api without
worrying about how it is achieved and
likewise the orchestration api
reliability engineer focuses on
delivering the the orchestration api
selling lot having to worry about the
applications that are not on top of it
this separation or deep up decoupling
means that a small team running acuities
cluster can be response for supporting
thousands of teams running on their
application in that cluster and finally
because in communities applications can
be co-located on the same machine
without impacting each other
this means the tasks from multiple users
can be packed tightly into fewer
machines this in turns provides a
greater efficiency and also results
reduces the cost of hardware as less
machines are used which means better
cost efficiencies so now that we are on
the same page let's talk about your
management structure before communities
arrived on the scene most organizations
picked an Orchestrator of choice so they
could have Jenkins or a gate tool of
choice that they worked out of depending
upon which customer I am talking to they
will often have separate organizations
managing their policies versus their
enclosure it's not let me say that
within the same organization especially
if it's large they agree on the same
choice of tools on the both side of the
house they will then couple their
Orchestrator with one or more client
that does the actuation and they may end
up using cloud deployment manager paluma
your terraform for the GCP
sources and help for Cuba nineties this
stacking and mixing of two says left to
this fragmented management and linear
language matrix that I talked about
where developers and operators have to
use a Rube Goldberg ish set of tools to
manage different resources type with
different providers the challenges that
any two organizations today are not
using these tools in a similar way and
often they are confusing inconsistencies
across UIs development environment
command lines SDKs configuration tools
and Docs and leading to increased
opportunity for customers to make an
error as you can imagine this can often
lead to workflows that can be hard to
occur straight across non-interoperable
tools which speak different languages
but wait there is more X cubed is
gaining Y adoption increasingly
customers have to operate in the weird
split brain mode when you're managing
your kubernetes cluster you have this
clean decorative language where you
order what you want it's like ordering
pizza you say medium pepperoni extra
cheese and the Pisa shows up magically
in those seven thirty minutes however
you imagine your legacy cloud you have
to use imperative api's with conflicting
standards now you have to be precise and
describe the entire recipe step by step
so if all you wanted was a database on
top of a sequel running on a VM you have
to go step by step and you have to say
hey spin up the VM then you pull the
thing you wait for couple of you know
minutes for the VM to come up then
you're like oh like populate the sequel
database and then the sequel database
comes up you pull it and then you're
like oh you know put the database inside
it and you have to basically ensure that
every step was completed successfully
before you can do the next step
this creates cognitive dissonance for
our customers and we decide to step in
and solve the problem conflict character
is a humanities plugin that allows
resources implemented by non communities
API is to be managed declaratively using
communities native configuration and
tooling users express their their
decorative intent for conflict connector
resources as a krm style yeah Mel
configuration which can then be applied
to a GK cluster just like any other cube
when it is resource the conflict
connector translates that declare intent
to the state of the underlying this
typically non-declarative define and
manage and metalize is it through calls
to the underlying API config connector
also manages the resources over time by
continuously D can sign the actual state
of the Hawaiian resource with
declarative intent so what does that
mean to you so there are three immediate
advantage firstly config character will
make all GCP resources behave as if they
were q and is the resources so now your
developers don't have to learn multiple
competing languages to manage the
instructure it's just a single conflict
or Yamla file and containing all in
fracture s code and you could apply the
single config yeah Mel file secondly you
achieve separation of concerns with
eventual consistency as a customer of
GCP using conflict connector you do not
really have to care about how Google
achieves the desired state you can ask
conflict connector to spin up a database
and pop it data in it and for some
reason we try to publish the data first
in a non existing database conflict
connector and gracefully back off wait
for the database to spin up and then
populate the database once things are up
and ready and finally because conflict
connector is relying on community serve
as a source of truth then first respond
up is self-healing
so for miscarried in turn comes in and
fat finger disease spanner conflict
character will notice the drift and
corrected to shake showcase all of this
and more I'm going to ask Greg to talk
us through the next set of slides
excellent thank you so I am as I said
Greg Donovan from Etsy and for the last
18 months or so I've been working on our
migration to gke as part of Etsy's
larger GTP migration from our on-prem
co-located bare-metal data centers and
i'm looking forward to sharing some of
our lessons migrating from bare metal to
gke and how config connector fits in so
what is that see Etsy is the global
marketplace for unique and creative kids
it's a large international and rapidly
growing marketplace we're constantly
trying to improve the product to keep up
with our buyers and sellers needs making
development velocity paramount searched
Etsy which I which I work on is an
especially fun problem it combines
large-scale systems in machine learning
problems real world impact and lots of
interesting products to think about
Betsey's headquarters is in brooklyn
where it was founded and we also have
engineering offices here in San
Francisco and Toronto Dublin and plenty
of remotes around the world Etsy started
in 2005 before the cloud and from 2005
to 2007 teen all the companies search
services ran and our co-located data
centers
I told 2060 and everything was pure bare
metal servers no VMS no containers then
in 2016 we built our first on-prem
kubernetes cluster and began migrating
our search applications over time to
kubernetes in 2017 the company decided
to move to GCP our on-prem kubernetes
migration morphed into a gke migration
which we finished up this spring when we
started our GCP migration we decided to
use terraform to provision our tcp
resources we use terraform for
everything except for our applications
and the kubernetes objects that they
create so what is terraform for those
unfamiliar terraform is a framework for
provisioning cloud resources using a
declarative configuration language
called HCL in addition to GCP it
supports AWS Azure other infrastructure
providers via their plug-in framework
underneath terraform represents our
resources as a graph with their
dependencies when you make terraform
changes it needs to reconcile your
declared
state with the actual state of these
resources for example does the gke
clustered name 'search exist does it
have the nude pools we've requested and
if there's a drift between your desired
state in the current state terraform
will figure out which api calls it needs
to make in order to reconcile the
desired in actual state and if you're
interested in learning more about the
underlying graph at work there's great
talk called applying graph theory to
infrastructure as code that I found very
helpful and to deploy terraform changes
we have a CI pipeline that uses Jenkins
validates that a terraform change is
valid gives you the output from a
terraform plan and then if human
approves the plan applies it we have a
single terraform mono repo with all the
company's cloud infrastructure giving us
a single place to audit refactor and a
single CI CD pipeline for all of this
now over in gke where search is
kubernetes does something very similar
or declared state is in our llamo
configuration the actual state is
determined by kubernetes usually by
consulting the @cd database that backs
its api when you call coop CTL apply
kubernetes will begin to reconcile what
you expressed that you wanted in yeah
Mille with what's actually in existence
so both terraformed kubernetes have
graphs with a notion of dependencies
each graph knows how to do a topological
sort
figure out what the order that it should
apply changes the kubernetes api is a
wonderful thing we're able to express
our infrastructure richly with an API
that works on any cloud provider on Prem
etc and we have assembled built in
kubernetes objects like deployment
stateful sets etc that can model our
infrastructure declaratively we also
take advantage of the kubernetes
extension mechanism custom resource
definitions to model objects at a higher
level for example we use the Prometheus
operator to deploy Prometheus it uses a
set of custom resource definitions to
model objects that are the core
abstractions in the Prometheus
installation Prometheus alert manager
service monitors and Prometheus rules
these then become top level objects in
kubernetes that we can manipulate with
coop CTL so I can do coop CTLs get
service monitors and see a list of
directives for Prometheus about what to
scrape CR DS make a lot of sense when
you analogize them to program
languages if pod services config maps
etc or like your primitive types custom
resource definitions allow you to build
higher level abstractions out of these
primitives there like Java classes but
for kubernetes and kubernetes has to
quote health Kelsey Hightower become the
POSIX API for distributed systems and so
at Etsy we deploy all of our search
services to gke we use the tech stack on
this life or a community's CI CD
pipeline which we'll see more of in the
upcoming demo suffice it to say we've
invested a huge amount of time and
effort to make this pipeline as fast and
powerful as we can Adolphe ear offers
speedy incremental reproducible builds
using basil especially for incremental
docker container layer builds and
programmatic control using Python over
the kubernetes yamo generated
specifically for each environment our
goal is to make deploy into kubernetes
fast reliable as customizable as you
need to be and as simple as we can make
it we want our search repo to be the one
place you need to make changes to launch
a new feature or create a brand-new
testing environment and for example a
PRF and workflow so if this seems
intriguing I gave a talk at basil Khan
last year about this stack and I'll be
speaking more about it at KU Khan in
Barcelona next month
or just email me unfortunately this
stack has a glaring weakness anytime we
want to make changes to GCP routes
resources it doesn't help us our two
worlds terraform and kubernetes do not
interact easily adding lots of friction
fragility and complexity to the
development process config connector is
designed to solve this problem so let's
show config connector in action in a
real setting I'd like to show you two
examples at Etsy that we targeted for
which config connector could make our
day-to-day development easier so as I
noted search is organized into a large
mono repo built with the basil build
tool since I can't open source our
entire code base for legal reasons I
created a demo app on github that serves
as a microcosm of our code base with a
whittled down version of much of the
scaffolding that we use to to in this
communities delivery pipeline
so you can see it here on github if you
want to pull it up and the demo is going
to show off two issues that we targeted
for a config connector first is how to
debug a problematic JVM so for JVM
Diagnostics we use the your kit profiler
with its detailed CPU memory and event
snapshot files and on an application
exit we are synched them from a pod
local directory to a GCS bucket and we
one of the GCS bucket names to be
dynamic based on their environment some
combination of the gke cluster the
namespace the pod name so the snapshots
were well organized didn't step on each
other's toes the second issue we wanted
config connector to help with is
structured login so for certain use
cases we'd like to stream logs directly
to bigquery so that we can perform
analytics on them and again we wanted
tine anak one-to-one mapping of data set
to application environment before commit
config connector we would need to go to
terraform every time we could in a new
environment so if you imagine that PR
driven workflow where you've got some
changes you want to make before actually
going to search and deploying your
changes you've got to go over to
terraform and you got to follow all
these steps and there might be some have
forgotten and what makes it more
difficult is that for example for a GCS
bucket you might want to create for your
your namespace well we have random slugs
attached to them for security reasons so
you know and then there are terraform
state files are encrypted so it adds a
lot of steps and another problem is Tara
forms configuration language it's very
very limited it makes a complex real
world configuration like we have it at C
very difficult for example if a simple
for loop over a map is almost impossible
to do without reading a blog post about
it in terraform so then we're not up to
that so let's go to the demo alright
so this is the the script we're gonna
run is the the main method of our pod
that starts up the server and then when
it exits it copies all of these snapshot
files to GCS and here is the service
itself set that bigquery sets up some
URL handlers rights to our structured
logs can say hello and goodbye just a
simple application to show how this
works and then this is the script that
gets called on shutdown to write those
snapshots to de GCS and we can also show
the structured log which is writing rows
to bigquery and here is how we use
Python and basil to generate dynamic
dynamic gamal that we send to kubernetes
so for example this target is calls sub
targets that generate a dynamic
namespace a dynamic GCS bucket a dynamic
bigquery data set and then our regular
kubernetes deployment so now this is not
the most dynamic example but if you
imagine you know QA environments versus
test environments different things you
might want to be testing so this is just
a Python with PI ml generating a
standard kubernetes deployment based on
your context you know what's your
namespace what's your cluster etc so
this is the application here's the
service that it uses but the more
interesting part comes when config
connector comes down so here is how we
create a GCS bucket so there's no
switching over to terraform we're using
a CR D so they config connector c rd
right here and now we get a new type
inside of our kubernetes cluster we have
a type called storage bucket and that is
provided by config connector that uh so
in announced today you can see we set up
the standard GCS bucket attributes like
it's life cycle when it gets deleted
after how long etc and then we do the
same for bigquery so we dynamically
create a big
data set we do the follow the bigquery
hoops for how you have to your name your
datasets
set up the table expiration a friendly
name etc and now we've got this new kind
within our data set a bigquery data set
so we've got these new super powers and
I'll show you one last bit which is how
we generate the underlying docker
container so it's a a Basel container
image target it takes a base docker
container add some scripts adds the your
kit files and outputs a docker image
alright so let's let's show it at work
so if we go we'll see we're in the CNR m
tcp next nineteen demo namespace and do
we have anything running we don't okay
so we're gonna hit that target that we
showed before that's going to deploy all
of those things so we're gonna try to
deploy one command the namespace the
deployment the service and the bigquery
data set and the GCS bucket so again
something that will require previously
multiple trips over to terraform to
generate these things cut and paste it
into our code base now it's one command
all right here it goes so we can see
here we go all right so we created the
namespace we configured the GCS bucket
now we can you can see these things in
action so now we do have a pod and we
can go say hi to it so let's let's first
see that it's up and running
okay listening on port 8000 let's go say
hi so I will set up port forwarding from
so now we have a port forward from my
laptop to the pod running inside GC
inside of gke and we can curl it to say
hello excellent and now we should be
able to see did it actually create those
storage buckets well shouldn't actually
yeah so there's the storage bucket and
we can see that the underlying CRD has
been created so let's describe it and
you can see the control loop in the in
the background this is up to date so
given the yam well we have here where we
describe what we wanted we wanted a
storage bucket with with these
parameters you know deleted after seven
days and there's a control loop in the
background making sure that those GCS
resources matches what we had in the
amal spec and we can see the same thing
with the big grey data set
and there it is the query data set
exists as we wanted it to but we should
if we go to the console now we can we
can see these resources right in the
console and there they are so the
storage bucket exists we can go over to
bigquery serially we did just create a
new data set just with coops ETL and
that's there and there's our logs table
and we should have some data in it there
we go
so when we said hello it wrote the hello
message so it's working and now when we
shut it down it should write those GCS
snapshots to the dynamically created
bucket very dramatic goodbye so let's
see if that actually worked look at that
so those are the the logs and snapshots
so when that JVM exited I wrote these
snapshots to the GCS bucket and so all
of this that would have required you
know multiple trips to terraform lots of
configuration now it's one coop CL CTL
command which is which is very exciting
so the demos worked so far should we
push our luck and try something a little
crazier let's make a new test
environment so what should we call our
new test environment let's call it
Michael okay so we have this so we have
this single source of truth
configuration for all of our
applications their namespaces etc so
here's where we defined previously the
the namespace that we wanted to have in
the app that we were deploying our
example app in which cluster we wanted
it to have it so now we're going to make
a new namespace that didn't exist so
this
is a a basal dot bzl file that is
defining this will call it Michael call
it Michael test so let's find the
dynamically created targets
okay so there's five targets we have a
new one for for each of those things
that we deployed previously to the the
other namespace and we'll deploy them to
the Michel namespace Deb it's a real
demo we're pushing our luck alright so
now it's going to generate llamo with
the new context this time the the Michel
test namespace and it's gonna make a new
new new create a new name space the new
GCSE buckets the new P query data set
the new service the new deployment and
let's actually switch over to that
namespace okay and the one thing that's
manual right now is getting the proper
credentials in there that is that is
something that we had workload identity
that's being announced shortly that this
manual step pool will go away so we put
the credentials that our pods need now
let's see if we have pods we do
and so if we go over here again now we
should see a new bigquery bigquery
dataset dynamically created just for
this namespace let's cross our fingers
and there it is there's the michael test
data set and that's up and going and we
should see the GCS buckets and there we
go excellent so a dynamically created
test environment with a single command
so imagine this in the context of a PR
driven workflow even engineer on the
team wants testing changes this is the
the fastest path to getting a new test
environment sort of meted out with your
with your parameters that involve
kubernetes infrastructure and GCP
infrastructure you can now do it in a
single command what we previously have
taken to see ICD pipelines different
approval steps etc etc can now be done
just with coops ETL so that that is
pretty exciting for us now back to Sona
that was amazing thank you Greg can we
switch back to the perfect magic so that
was amazing
let's move on to the Q&A section I'll
ask Michael to come up on stage as we
get set up over here
Greg you too you don't get any rest for
people that arrived a bit late
I would suggest downloading the cloud
next step the app allows you to ask
questions and upload questions in the
audience it's super easy to use also
before we get started if you would like
to participate in our alpha please check
us out on github it's a closed alpha we
have limited capacity so I would suggest
getting on this quickly also if you hate
typing just point our Android or iPhone
camera to the QR code and you should see
a pop up on your camera that takes you
to that page all we need is the email of
the user or service account that you'll
be using to run conflict err and we can
get you up and running with that let's
go to the Dory and Michael the four is
yours
[Music]